Eddie, you are a cancer to
everyone who ever loved you let me
he's a serial killer and now he's
got an alien inside him chaos chaos
you know how much i love an underdog
so
for as long as i can remember i have
looked for an equal one who could push me
one who could surprise me
one who could even beat me
yet all i found is disappointment
will one of you finally give me what i desire
yes
we will
Welcome back everyone this will be my new venom
let there be carnage trailer there's a bunch of
new footage we've also got the marvel spider-man 2
trailer with a whole other version of venom during
that so i'll explain what's going on because we
also have the miles morales you also have the
whole sinister six of it all and craven showing up
as another new villain so we'll break it all down
there's a whole bunch of easter eggs it's like
trailer city right now if you're brand new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos i will be doing a lot of videos for the
venom let there be carnage movie but i'll also do
videos for marvel spider-man 2 when they release
more footage for that but like the trailer says
marvel spider-man 2 is not going to be released
until 2023 so it is going to be a hot minute
before they start releasing a whole bunch more
footage for that so start with the new venom let
there be carnage stuff and since we got the last
big trailer for that we also got the spider-man
no way home trailer and if you remember earlier
this year i did a video after the president of
sony's movie studio said that spider-man no way
home would be the key to explaining or the movie
would explain how they're going to connect all the
mcu spider-man stuff with all the sony spider-man
stuff the spin-offs the venom movies morbius all
the other sinister six movies they're planning
so now the eventual venom spider-man crossover is
starting to make a little more sense but venom
lithography carnage is all about the carnage
origin story and we just found out the movie is
only going to be about 90 minutes long meaning
it's going to be relatively short one of the
shortest marvel related movies since howard the
duck that's right george lucas's howard the duck
from back in the day but all that means is there's
not going to be a whole lot of fluff like they're
going to get into the action really quickly it
also means they're probably not going to kill
carnage off for good at the end of the film which
i think is a smart move he just way too big of a
character to be a one and done kind of character
we got the spider-man crossover coming up
eventually hopefully they'll do a true version
of spider-man maximum carnage in the movies
at some point because if you didn't read the
original comic book spider-man maximum carnage
also featured a carnage in shriek team-up with
him breaking her out of prison which he's doing
during this trailer so it sounds like they're
just creating the circumstances that would
make it possible for them to actually do that
in a future movie after this one but there's a
brand new scene of eddie going to visit cletus
cassidy inside the prison before they execute him
cletus tells eddie that he's a cancer to everyone
who ever loved him and they're obviously trying
to hype up the anne weighing of it all with him
visiting her him still having feelings for her
even the venom symbiote is like that should be
us getting married to her the funny thing
that andy circus the director said about
the different relationships in the movie because
there's lots of different kinds of relationships
like you have the relationship between eddie brock
and the symbiote the relationship between cletus
cassidy and the carnage symbiote then like the
actual human relationships the way andy circus
described the movie like the quick funny elevator
speech like tell it to me in under five seconds
is that the movie is a love story between eddie
brock and an alien lump of goo which is true in a
funny kind of way like eddie brock in the comics
if you read any of the comic books has just the
weirdest most dysfunctional relationship with the
symbiote you've ever seen but he's kind of been
married to the symbiote so to speak this whole
time even though he has other human relationships
but cletus is clearly trying to get under eddie's
skin and just piss him off the venom symbiote
screaming he's rude asking to eat him then lashing
out just slamming him against the wall and up
against the bars you can kind of tell that this is
happening at a point in the movie when eddie and
the venom symbiotes relationship is at the height
of his discord the whole idea that they're kind of
fighting each other from control of eddie's body
because the symbiote wants to be a predator and
eddie does not want to eat people left and right
but when the symbiote slams cletus against the
bars he bites eddie's hand drawing blood except
it's not regular blood as cletus says in the
other trailer that's not blood i've tasted blood
but in this scene you actually see him staring at
the symbiote infused blood for a second kind of
fascinated and confused by it until he tastes it
like what the hell is this and that is how he gets
the carnage symbiote with it slowly propagating in
his bloodstream until they get to the point where
they're going to execute him and it fully emerges
from his body to save him but i think the idea
being that this piece of the symbiote regenerates
itself into a completely different symbiote
so that when it speaks to him inside his body
his voice doesn't sound like the venom symbiote's
voice and if you didn't know this fun fact it's
actually tom hardy who does the voice of the
venom symbiote they just modulate his voice
like he's doing a voice but they also process it
so that it sounds like this alien symbiote voice
but it's basically tom hardy speaking to himself
when he's doing scenes with the venom symbiote in
the comics the klyntar the race that the symbiotes
belong to they can actually spawn themselves they
have asexual reproduction they just eventually
spawn new copies of themselves and those are
like these children so i think the version that
they're doing in the movie here is meant to be
a combination of those concepts the comic book
spawning along with cletus literally ingesting
eddie's symbiote-infused blood then there's
a brand new scene of eddie talking to someone
different about carnage about the actual carnage
symbiote this might be detective patrick mulligan
who seems like he has some other history with
cletus cassidy predating this the way they played
in the trailer it seems like he's really pissed
off with all the articles that eddie is writing
so maybe he was the detective that originally put
cletus in prison but there's the whole thing with
the daily bugle article that he's writing about
all the unfound bodies that cletus is revealing
to him it sort of bait him to come visit him in
prison like i'll tell you about all these people
that i buried that nobody ever found so that might
be why patrick mulligan is so pissed off because
he was the lead detective and he did not find all
those mystery bodies there's a bunch more footage
of carnage breaking him out of prison more footage
of his girlfriend shriek when she's being broken
out of ravencroft she's being kept in ravencroft
institute over in new york city which you remember
from the andrew garfield amazing spider-man 2
movie so we've had all these conversations about
how tom holland's spider-man could logically cross
over with venom so when venom let there be carnage
carnage going to new york city to break shriek
out of ravencroft is just the key to that
like oh this is why we're moving the story in the
movie to new york city and you also have eddie
brock working for j jonah jameson now in this
version of the daily bugle there is supposed to
be a jk simmons cameo in the movie with a version
of j jonah jameson but i don't know what he's
going to look like because one of the other major
differences in some of these easter eggs between
venomous derby carnage and spider-man no way
home is that the mcu version of the daily bugle
has a different font like a different logo than
this version the daily bugle in the venom trailer
the one in the venom trailer has the same logo
from the tope mcguire spider-man movies the
mcu one that they introduced during spider-man
far from home is totally different so even
though we're getting a bunch of jk simmons j
jonah jameson cameos in the morbius movie and
venomotherpy carnage and spider-man no way home
they might all be slightly different versions i'm
sure there's a joke in there somewhere about a j
jonah jameson multiverse war against spider-man
just like the kang multiverse war only they're
just after spider-man but just talking about
the marvel spider-man 2 trailer footage obviously
it's just a really quick teaser meant to let you
know who the major characters who the villains are
going to be and when they're planning on releasing
it so clearly miles morales is wearing the brand
new suit that he got from the miles morales game
that they just released a little while ago but
you also have peter parker spider-man wearing the
advanced suit with the iron spider legs so it's
like an advanced suit version of the iron spider
suit the big easter egg in the background here too
obviously the voice is craven i think we're all in
agreement that it's craving the hunter and they're
just doing more sinister six villains slowly
over the spider-man sequels maybe when we get to
spider-man 3 or marvel spider-man 4 maybe that's
when we'll do a full-blown version of spider-man
vs the sinister six you also probably noticed the
easter eggs in the background here too mikhail's
diner is similar to mick's diner from the first
spider-man the one with the big stanley cameo this
is meant to be a different diner though but you
get the similarity mix diner mikhail's diner and
in the background on the street sign here it says
goodman martin goodman was the person who hired
stan lee originally as part of timely comics than
when they became marvel comics like he was the
person who owned the business itself but then
you get the big venom reveal paying off the post
credit scene from the first marvel spider-man game
with the harry osborne looking version of venom
but he's being voiced the venom symbiotes being
voiced by tony todd candy man himself but if there
was any confusion i think the idea they're trying
to present here is that miles morales will also be
a playable character during this new spider-man 2
storyline just because they spent so much time
developing the character in the previous games
everyone post all your reactions to all this brand
new footage and if you spotted any big easter eggs
in either of these trailers that i didn't talk
about in the video just write them below in the
comments it is going to be crazy for the rest of
the year we're also going to be getting a bunch
of marvel eternals trailer footage really soon
too because that move is coming out in november
and big reminder venom let there be carnage
is coming out at the beginning of october
now they moved it up because the shang
chi movie did so well at the box office
my full marvel what if episode 6 video will post
wednesday just like normal make sure you have
alerts enabled so you don't miss that everyone
click here for my full shang chi post credit scene
video and click here for my full what if episode 5
marvel zombies video with zombie hunter spider-man
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you in the next video!